design first play you come out you
execute it well there's that bully ball
walton has decided to play early you
know that was the game plan though
williams knocks down the three they were
red hot last night 15 of 30.
and now we see home green inside outside
opportunity also a great passer
rebounder shot blocker
in a 7-5 game early make it now 7-7 on
that bucket they do
often inside let's see if he can knock
down the three pull the trigger downtown
and look at the swagger coming from the
big fella
we've stayed in contact over these years
as you know we've gone our separate ways
but he knows basketball a very high
level has been proven to be on a lot of
successful teams runs at front court
ball batted down by waters the dish
inside my oh my homegrown with a quick
donkey
or zaire williams xavier tillman senior
uh jake lareva
arabia wow what a deep one wow
by kenny just pulls up shot clock
running down
grabs it off the dribble
doesn't take him a lot of power to get
that ball that far either so you see
john
jump out that chair
another rebound fires the three that's a
versatility of that big there's a quick
output pass loft and cherry-picking a
bit left-hand caught the rim and then
coming out to block that shot holdren
enough space there
chet goes up
and i think he has
some fingernails because it caught the
end
right of
a finger right there and that's a
blocked shot he's very good at that i
mean obviously
he played for a guy with a nice two-hand
block right there
two quick blocks here in the quarter and
he is he's fatigued he is dead tired so
is uh krejci at the moment